Jake:202404 呃
Jake: 202404, uh...
Jake:开了对吧
Jake: It's on, right?
Shure: 我早开了你
Shure: I turned it on long ago.
Jake:都开了都开了
Jake: All turned on, all turned on.
Jack: 你用过hrm吗
Jack: Have you used HRM before?
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 来来来他就会蹦出来这个
Shure: Come on, it will just pop up.
Choiszt: 这是傻瓜教学
Choiszt: This is idiot-proof teaching.
Shure: 不我环境都没好呢
Shure: No, my environment isn't ready yet.
Shure: yes
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 然后他会
Shure: And then it will...
Shure: 给我报这个什么
Shure: Report to me this, what's it called...
Shure: trouble shooting some counter package install
Shure: Trouble shooting some counter package install.
Shure: 啦啦啦for example
Shure: La la la, for example.
Jack: 不你你现在放那可是一个新的环境啊
Jack: No, you're setting it up in a new environment now.
Shure: 啊可以
Shure: Ah, okay.
Jack: 对你可也得
Jack: Yes, you still have to...
Jack: 就是缺什么装什么
Jack: Just install whatever is missing.
Jack: 这个绝对最快
Jack: This is definitely the fastest.
Lucia: 我决定来蹭一个冰淇淋
Katrina: 你要不去拿个勺子
Lucia: 还有勺吗
Katrina: 嗯那个厨房里有勺
Lucia: 啊对我们买了新勺
Jack: 必给你跑起来
Jack: For sure.
Shure: 我相信你们的
Shure: I believe you guys.
Choiszt: 登我号
Choiszt: Log into my account.
Jack: 你就随便可以
Jack: You can just...
Jack: 你看看你python的版本
Lucia: 妈呀这东西也太多了吧
Lucia: 在哪边呢
Jake:你琢磨琢磨
Jake: Think about it
Shure: 我酒冰饮料
Shure: Alcohol, ice, drinks
Shure: 就饮品上补齐就行
Shure: Just restock the beverages
Lucia: 我们应该买了好多
Lucia:补什么
Lucia: Restock what?
Jake:补什么
Jake: Restock what?
Lucia:哦装饰吗
Lucia: Oh, decorations?
Jake:要补上补货
Jake: Need to restock supplies
Jake:我们要买东西的话你要补什么货吗
Jake: If we're buying stuff, do you need to restock anything?
Jake:雨轩要补货吗
Jake: Does Yuxuan need to restock?
Katrina: 我思考一下
Lucia: 我想一想
Lucia:如果有蓝色系的明信片的话
Lucia: If there are blue postcards
Lucia:或者那种装饰纸的话
Lucia: Or
Katrina: 你找找我那明信片里面有
Katrina: You should check, I might have some postcards
Katrina: 有没有蓝色的
Katrina: Do you have a blue one?
Lucia:啊对也可以就地取材一下
Lucia: Ah, right, we can just use whatever's available.
Shure: 变成那个康纳的那个环境来着
Shure: It's turning into Connor's environment, right?
Lucia: 因为我觉得我那照片
Lucia:墙上可能需要戳两个
Lucia: We might need to mark a couple spots on the wall.
Lucia:但是当时好像买了也来不及
Lucia: But it seemed like we couldn't buy it in time back then.
Lucia:太不太来得及倒
Lucia: It was too rushed at that time.
Jake:这玩意要收起来了吗
Jake: Should we put this thing away?
Jake:可以收收
Jake: Yeah, we can put it away.
Katrina: 旺仔牛奶是不是要买
Katrina: 美纹纸跟旺仔牛奶是吧
Lucia:美纹纸我买了他今天应该到了
Katrina: 那那旺仔牛奶是不是要外送
Katrina: So, should we deliver the milk?
Katrina: 要大概几瓶
Katrina: How many bottles do we need?
Tasha: 嗯两瓶
Tasha: Hmm, two bottles.
Katrina: 那就买那种
Katrina: Then let's get that kind.
Katrina: 一板一板
Katrina: The one with a whole pack.
Tasha: 一板就行
Tasha: One pack is enough.
Jake:来我们来记个小本本
Jake: Let's jot this down in our notebook.
Katrina: 黑板可以拿出来了
Katrina: We can take out the blackboard now.
Jake:好啊好啊
Jake: Sure, sure.
Katrina: 户外教学
Katrina: Outdoor teaching.
Lucia: 哎为什么我们今天成了户外的
Choiszt: 你要配那个干啥
Choiszt: Why do you need to match that?
其他人：他要干活我就可以不干活
Jake:来来个人抬黑板吧来来来
Jake: Someone help carry the blackboard, come on.
Jack: 你每次每次叼的是同一个吗
Jack: Do you always bite the same one?
Jack: 不知道可能吧
Jack: I don't know, maybe.
Lucia:每次叼的是同一个吧
Lucia: You always drop the same one, right?
Jack: 你别他妈这一盒全部也叼下去了
Jack: Don't just take the whole damn box.
其他人：八根转我20块钱就行了
其他人：这一共多少20根
其他人：嗯
其他人：我觉得可以买点槟榔
其他人：你是不是想害人
Choiszt: 不是那你说能买啥
Nicous: 巧克力棒
Jake:放边上吧
Jake: Put it on the side.
Jake:放放那放这个最左边
Jake: Put it there, on the far left.
Jake:有个阴凉比较好看
其他人：正对阳光
Others: Facing the sunlight.
Jake:正对阳光也行吧
Jake: Facing the sunlight works too.
Shure: 采购装饰打扫甜点QA
Jake:这光是怎么打的
Jake: How's the lighting?
其他人：QA是什么
Katrina: 那是我写的m
Katrina: That was my writing.
Katrina: 哈哈哈q and a我不太会画那个符号
Katrina: Hahaha, Q and A, I'm not good at drawing that symbol.
Katrina: 就是地球世界地球日的那个问答
Katrina: It's the Earth Day Q&A symbol.
Choiszt: 哦那还要准备问题是吗
Choiszt: Oh, so we need to prepare questions too?
Jake:对要准备问题
Jake: Yes, we need to prepare questions.
Jake:GPT准备问题
Jake:哈哈我们中午准备了一些问题
Jake: Haha, we prepared some questions at noon.
Jake:比如说比如说啥来着
Jake: Like, like what again?
Katrina: 中午那是是问题吗
Katrina: Was that a question at noon?
Lucia:中午那不是问题那只是大家想的
Lucia: That wasn't a question, it was just what everyone thought.
Lucia:就是不是
Lucia: Exactly, it wasn't.
Jake:问题一不孕不育会遗传吗
Jake: First question, is infertility hereditary?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Katrina: 黑板擦没拿是不是
Katrina: Didn't you bring the chalkboard eraser?
Lucia:我觉得不止这个问题
Lucia: I think there's more than just this question.
Lucia:还有什么来着
Lucia: What else was there?
Choiszt: 是不孕不育是基因突变导致的吗
Jake:什么健胃消食片
Jake: What about digestive aid tablets?
Jake:能吃饱吗
Jake: Can they make you full?
Jack: 健胃消食片能吃饱吗
Jack: Can digestive aid tablets make you full?
Jack: 能绝对可以它含糖呀
Jack: Absolutely, they contain sugar.
Lucia:大家都很有逻辑的在回答一些问题
Lucia: Everyone is logically answering some questions.
Jake:对可多了
Jake: Yes, there are so many.
Shure: 现在要干嘛来着
Shure: What are we doing now?
Jake:我们现在盘算盘算要买啥然后去买
Jake: We're planning what to buy and then go buy it.
其他人：你们盘算吧我继续搞币了
Jake:你去干嘛
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake:搞币哦你在这搞币吧
Jake: Mining coins? Oh, you're mining coins here.
Jake:为什么每次都能砸中陨石坑
Jake: Why do we always hit the crater?
Lucia:哦哦这个比较搞笑
Lucia: Oh, that's pretty funny.
Katrina: 那黑板擦呢
Katrina: What about the chalkboard eraser?
Jake:在里面
Jake: It's inside.
Katrina: 拿了
Katrina: Got it.
Katrina: 列一下吧
Katrina: Let's list it out.
Katrina: 美文纸买了是吧
Katrina: Did we buy the fancy paper?
Lucia: 买了
Katrina: 他说他买了
Katrina: He said he bought it.
Lucia:应该到了
Lucia: It should have arrived.
Lucia:我今天收到他的取货码
Lucia: I received the pickup code today.
Jake:黑板擦在哪
Jake: Where's the chalkboard eraser?
Tasha: 在哪
Tasha: Where is it?
Lucia:什么这也是奇葩问题吗难道
Lucia: What, is this a weird question too?
Jake:这不是奇葩问题
Jake: This isn't a weird question.
Jake:这是给AI的好问题
Jake: It's a good question for AI.
Katrina: 冰块也有了
Katrina: We have ice cubes too.
Katrina: 那就只要送旺仔
Katrina: Then we just need to deliver Wangzai.
Tasha: 不需要外送了
Tasha: No need for delivery.
Tasha: 我们等会去采购
Tasha: We'll go shopping later.
Katrina: 我们等会出去买呀
Katrina: We'll go buy it later?
Tasha: 对啊我们等会出去
Tasha: Yeah, we'll go out later.
Katrina: 我们等会要出去买啊
Katrina: We'll go out to buy it later?
Jake:出去买
Jake: Go out to buy it.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Jake:也可以不出
Jake: Or we don't have to.
Jake:可以派一波人出去买
Jake: We can send a group to buy it.
Tasha:没网我靠我说呢
Tasha: No internet, I knew it.
Jake:最近天太好了
Jake: The weather has been too good lately.
Jake:竟然都不下雨
Jake: It hasn't rained at all.
Jake:HTTP error 没网了
Jake: HTTPL has no internet.
Jake:服务器没网了
Jake: The server has no internet.
Jack: 我他本地没网
Jack: My local has no internet.
Shure: 不是这是服务器的啊
Shure: No, it's the server.
Katrina: 采购清单
Katrina: Shopping list.
Jack: 啊这服务器的
Jack: Ah, it's the server.
Jake:服务器没网了
Jake: The server has no internet.
Jake:没钱了
Jake: No money.
Shure: 怎么可能
Shure: How is that possible?
Shure: 我今天早上刚给他充100
Shure: I just topped it up with 100 this morning.
董超超你：是不是没有
Jack: Didn't you?
其他人：来看看
Others: Let's take a look.
Jack: 就你没开Brox的
Jack: You didn't open Brox.
Choiszt: 哎这不这可以
Choiszt: Hey, isn't this possible?
Jack: 这不能装吗
Jack: Can't this be installed?
Jack: 这么快啊
Jack: So fast?
Lucia:我刚才一直看那张纸
Lucia: I was just looking at that paper.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Jack: 一秒一秒跑90%
Jack: It's running 90% per second.
Shure: 这5005百k每秒的
Shure: This is 500, 500k per second.
Shure: 不可能这绝逼是假的这个东西
Shure: No way, this has to be fake.
Jake:Cache肯定是Cache Cache
Jake: It must be cache, definitely cache.
Shure: 什么叫Cache
Shure: Cache是什么意思
Jake:缓存
Jake: Cache.
Lucia:Cache那个单词吗
Jake:CHE对CHE对
Jake: CHE, right, CHE.
Lucia:che  sorry
Lucia: che
Lucia:哦原来那个文件夹是这个意思
Lucia: Oh, so that's what the folder means.
Jake:嗯是
Jake: Yeah, that's right.
Jake:就随便删的意思
Jake: It means you can delete it freely.
Lucia:我想搁那整理自己的那个啥
Lucia: I was planning to put my stuff there.
Lucia:系统的时候
Lucia: When I was organizing the system.
Tasha:靠
Tasha: Damn.
Lucia:那就好
Katrina: 上次那个葡萄汁兑酒好喝吗
Katrina: How was the grape juice mixed with alcohol last time?
Lucia:葡萄汁
Lucia: The grape juice?
Katrina: 上次是他
Katrina: It was him last time.
Katrina: 你喝的葡萄是吗
Katrina: Did you drink the grape juice?
Lucia:哦那个我喝了一口
Lucia: Oh, I took a sip.
Lucia:我觉得一般吧
Lucia: I thought it was just okay.
Lucia:不过看大家了
Lucia: But it's up to everyone.
Katrina: 我感觉西柚的蛮好喝哦
Katrina: I think the grapefruit one is quite good.
Jake:好西柚可以
Jake: Alright, grapefruit is good.
Lucia:呃西柚的比葡萄的好喝一点
Lucia: Uh, the grapefruit one is a bit better than the grape one.
Katrina: 那橙汁的我也觉得一般般
Katrina: I also think the orange juice one is just so-so.
Lucia:因为我们上次买的是朗姆
Lucia: Because we bought rum last time.
Jake:就西柚疯狂西柚
Jake: Just go crazy with the grapefruit.
Lucia:就是橙汁
Lucia: Just orange juice.
Lucia:其实应该兑龙舌兰
Lucia: Actually, it should be mixed with tequila.
Katrina: 哦我们现在有
Katrina: 那要不要再买一瓶气泡酒
Katrina: Should we buy another bottle of sparkling wine?
Lucia:气泡酒还有一瓶
Lucia: We still have a bottle of sparkling wine.
Lucia: 有一个那个金色的那个气泡酒
Lucia: There's a golden bottle of sparkling wine.
其他人：买那个旺仔牛奶
Jack: Buy that Want Want milk.
其他人：那个旺仔牛奶配百利甜
Jack: That Want Want milk goes well with Baileys.
Lucia:你要甜死我
Lucia: You're going to make me sick with sweetness.
Choiszt: 好像还是能下
Choiszt: I think it might still go down.
其他人：红石榴长江龙舌兰日出
Others: Pomegranate, Changjiang, Tequila Sunrise.
Katrina: 咱咱还有什么酒来
Katrina: What other alcohol do we have?
Katrina: 那一瓶是什么呀
Katrina: What's that bottle?
Katrina: 还有什么酒
Katrina: What other alcohol do we have?
Katrina: 气泡气泡的有一瓶
Katrina: We have one bottle of sparkling.
Lucia:39 那个开了
Lucia: The 39, that one's opened.
Shure: 汽个气气泡的
Shure: Sparkling, we have a bottle of sparkling.
Katrina: 然后还有呢
Katrina: And what else?
Katrina: 还有就是朗姆的半瓶
Katrina: And there's half a bottle of rum.
Lucia:郎姆小半瓶现在
Lucia: Half a bottle of rum now.
Katrina: 那就是一些吃的
Katrina: Then there's some food.
Shure: 你可以你是不是一会不去对吧
Shure: Are you not going later, right?
Shure: 买东西的话
Shure: If you’re buying stuff...
Lucia:不过我觉得百利甜值得考虑
Lucia: But I think Baileys is worth considering.
Lucia:因为不太会踩雷
Lucia: Because it's not likely to be a miss.
Lucia:不过我觉得
Lucia: But I think...
Lucia:刚才谢明竹说那个百利甜值得考虑
Lucia: Just now, Xie Mingzhu said Baileys is worth considering.
Lucia:因为感觉不是太会踩雷
Lucia: Because it doesn't seem like a miss.
Lucia:可能大家会比较想
Lucia: Maybe people would prefer it.
Lucia:百百利甜是一种甜酒
Lucia: Baileys is a type of sweet liquor.
Jack: 我靠还买了香槟
Jack: Whoa, you even bought champagne.
Lucia:利口酒
Lucia: It's a liqueur.
Shure: 也不是香槟吧
Shure: It's not champagne, right?
Shure: 就气泡酒
Shure: It's just sparkling wine.
Tasha: 香槟
Tasha: Champagne.
Lucia:反正一般女生会比较不踩雷
Lucia: Generally, girls are less likely to dislike it.
Lucia:喝那个的话
Lucia: If they drink that.
Tasha: 说要买瓶香槟
Tasha: They said to buy a bottle of champagne.
Katrina: 香槟真的假的
Katrina: Champagne, really?
Katrina: 那个
Katrina: That...
Shure: 那个就行
Shure: That will do.
Lucia:那个就行吧应该
Lucia: That should be fine, I guess.
Shure: 嗯能崩一下
Shure: Yeah, it can pop a bit.
Shure: 就就就可以了
Shure: That’s good enough.
Katrina: 北冰洋还要买吗
Katrina: Should we buy Beibingyang?
Katrina: 哦哦可乐没了
Katrina: Oh, we're out of Coke.
Jack: 刚我看上面不是币安吗
Tasha:茶
Katrina: 茶是什么
Katrina: 茶这样写吗
Lucia:就那个维他柠檬茶
Lucia: It's that Vita lemon tea.
Tasha: 直接叫茶吗
Katrina: 哪个叫什么
Katrina: Which one is called what?
Katrina: 什么是茶啊
Tasha: 维他茶
Tasha: Vita tea.
Lucia:反正在我们
Lucia: Anyway, in our...
Katrina: 哦我以为他写了哈哈
Katrina: Oh, I thought he wrote it, haha.
Lucia:反正在我们的目标观众地区
Lucia: Anyway, in our target audience area...
Lucia:我刚那句话要不要删掉
Lucia: Should I delete what I just said?
Jake:呵呵呵部分
Jake: Hehehe, partly.
Jake:部分合法
Jake: Partly legal.
Katrina: 你还需要草莓吗
Katrina: Do you still need strawberries?
Jake:部分合法
Jake: Partly legal.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 蓝莓是不是没拆
Tasha: Haven't the blueberries been unpacked?
Katrina: 蓝莓吃掉了啊
Katrina: The blueberries were eaten.
Tasha:啊什么时候
Tasha: Oh, when?
Tasha: 什么时候吃掉的
Tasha: When did you eat them?
Tasha:为什么没带我
Tasha: Why didn't you take me?
Katrina: 洗了那一天不知道什么
Katrina: The day we washed them, I don't know...
Lucia:前两天吧好像
Lucia: A few days ago, I think.
Tasha: 为什么没带我
Tasha: Why didn't you take me?
Lucia:因为那个如果再放好像就会坏
Lucia: Because if we left them any longer, they would have gone bad.
Lucia:所以我们就已经把它吃掉了哈哈
Lucia: So we just ate them already, haha.
Katrina: 青提可以兑酒
Katrina: Green grapes can be mixed with wine.
Katrina: 青提
Katrina: Green grapes.
Tasha: 青提还有榴莲
Tasha: Green grapes and durian.
Jack: 你已经熟练的使用度假工具
Jack: You have become proficient at using vacation tools.
Katrina: 你要榴莲是吧
Katrina: You want durian, right?
Katrina: 你喜欢吃榴莲是不
Katrina: You like eating durian, don't you?
Tasha: 嗯哎
Tasha: Yeah, hey.
Jake:可以继续度假
Lucia:哎我们之前买那盒榴莲吃完了吗
Lucia: Hey, did we finish the box of durian we bought earlier?
Tasha: 他偷偷吃掉了
Tasha: He ate it secretly.
Jake:我怎么偷偷吃了
Jake: How did I eat it secretly?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Jake:塞我嘴里了
Jake: It was stuffed into my mouth.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:塞我嘴里
Lucia: Stuffed into my mouth.
Tasha: 你吃没吃
Tasha: Did you eat it?
Jake:吃了吃了
Jake: Yes, I did.
Jake:确实吃了
Jake: I really did.
Tasha: 你看他偷偷吃掉了
Tasha: See, he ate it secretly.
Shure: 猫也挂着呢
Shure: The cat is also hanging around.
Shure: 我给你开global行不
Shure: Can I get you global access?
Jake:有个上海的电话
Jake: There's a call from Shanghai.
Katrina: 上海谁给我打电话
Katrina: Who's calling me from Shanghai?
Jake:上海电话
Jake: A call from Shanghai.
Jack: 上海邮电大学
Jack: Shanghai University of Posts and Telecommunications.
Jake:上海邮电大
Jake: Shanghai University of Posts and Telecom.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Hey.
Katrina: 那明天就是那个串要买吗
Katrina: So, are we buying those skewers tomorrow?
Jake:串就美团吧
Jake: Let's just get them from Meituan.
Katrina: 烤吗
Katrina: Grilled, right?
Jake:美团吧明天买
Jake: Yeah, let's buy them from Meituan tomorrow.
Katrina: 那就烤点串
Katrina: Then let's grill some skewers.
Katrina: 然后那个炭啊什么的都有了是吧
Katrina: So, we have charcoal and all that, right?
Tasha: 我们美团买的
Tasha: We bought it from Meituan.
Tasha: 意思是美团烧烤店买
Tasha: I mean, from a Meituan barbecue shop.
Tasha: 哈哈哈然后来
Tasha: Haha, and then...
其他人：在烧烤店买点熟的碳
Jake:哈哈哈买点炭灰哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, let's buy some charcoal ash, haha.
Lucia:买点熟的碳
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia:又是一个弱智吧问题
Lucia: Another dumb question, huh?
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:明天要是这天气就太阳能烤
Jake: If the weather's like this tomorrow, we can grill with solar power.
Katrina: 还有那个如果说要唱歌的话
Katrina: And if we want to sing, can your sound system connect to a microphone?
Katrina: 你音响能接话筒吗
Katrina: Do you have a microphone?
Katrina: 有话筒吗
Katrina: Any microphones?
Shure: 没有话筒
Shure: No microphones.
Jake:没有话筒怎么搞
Jake: How are we supposed to do it without a microphone?
Shure: 买花租买花租
Shure: Buy, rent, buy, rent.
Shure: 买话筒
Shure: Buy a microphone.
Katrina: 租吧
Katrina: Let's rent one.
Jack: 拼多多9块9话筒
Jack: Pinduoduo has microphones for 9.9 yuan.
Jake:哦真的
Jake: Oh, really?
Katrina: 那种就小小的一个话筒
Katrina: Those small microphones.
Tasha:小唱吧
Tasha: Like a mini karaoke.
Shure: 大概一话筒就100多块钱搞一个
Shure: A decent microphone costs over 100 yuan.
Jake:可以搞
Tasha: 租一个吧
Tasha: Let's rent one.
Tasha: 现在买还来得及吗
Tasha: Can we still buy one now?
Shure: 费劲
Shure: Too much hassle.
Alice:明天天气比今天再热一点哦
Alice: Tomorrow's weather will be even hotter than today.
Jake:真的
Jake: Really?
Tasha: 怎么要买空调吗
Tasha: Are we buying an air conditioner?
Jake:哈哈哈室外空调大风扇
Jake: Hahaha, an outdoor air conditioner, a big fan.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
其他人：买那个买那个
Others: Buy that one, buy that one.
其他人：烤肉用的
Others: For BBQ.
其他人：烤肉用的超大
Others: Super big for BBQ.
Tasha: 冰风扇那种是吗
Tasha: Like an ice fan, right?
Katrina: 哎是不是那个小青柠还在呢
Katrina: Hey, is that little lime still there?
Tasha: 在呢
Tasha: Yeah, it's still there.
Jake:北邮能带东西回来是吧
Katrina: 芒果还需要吗
Katrina: Do we still need mangoes?
Tasha: 需要什么来着
Tasha: What else do we need?
Tasha: 不要了
Tasha: We don't need it anymore.
Shure: 哦也有哎
Shure: Oh, there's that too.
Lucia:我们就应该买龙舌兰的
Lucia: We should buy tequila.
Tasha: 干嘛干嘛干嘛
Tasha: Why, why, why?
Lucia:哦没事
Lucia: Oh, nothing.
Lucia:我就随口一说
Lucia: I just said it casually.
Jake:下下午2点半
Jake: At 2:30 in the afternoon.
Lucia:如果大家觉得能喝完的话
Lucia: If everyone thinks we can finish it.
Katrina: 要不就把朗姆换成龙舌兰
Katrina: How about we replace the rum with tequila?
Katrina: 都行我不太懂
Katrina: I'm fine with it, I don't really know.
Lucia:今天今天买酒还买朗姆吗
Lucia: Are we still buying rum today?
Katrina: 换那就换呗
Katrina: Replace it then.
Lucia:那就换龙舌兰呗
Lucia: Then let's get tequila.
Lucia:就是大家可以尝尝不同的口味吗
Lucia: So everyone can try different flavors.
Jake:早早点来早点来
Jake: Come earlier, come earlier.
Choiszt: 音响就用你现在这个对
Choiszt: Just use this sound system, right?
Katrina: 什么话筒
Katrina: What about the microphone?
Katrina: 有是吗
Katrina: Do we have it?
Shure: 话筒北邮有
Shure: The microphone, there's one at Beiyou.
Shure: 有他们来的时候给我取了就行
Shure: When they come, they can get it for me.
Katrina: 借一下呗
Katrina: Just borrow it.
其他人：你要把这个带过来
Others: You need to bring this over.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is it?
其他人：推波波
Others: Push ball.
Jake:台球
Jake: Billiards.
Lucia:你刚才做的我还以为是小提琴
Lucia: What you were doing just now, I thought it was a violin.
其他人：这不是很像推波波
Others: Doesn't it look like push ball?
Jake:你们都狠着打的
Jake: You guys are all playing hard.
Katrina: 你主要是你的那个缺还缺啥材料吗
Katrina: Mainly, do you still need any materials for that?
Shure: 我被称为北邮丁俊晖
Tasha:好像不缺啥了
Tasha: Seems like we don't need anything else.
Tasha: 我的妈呀
Tasha: Oh my gosh
Shure: 听说你叫北邮奥沙利文
Shure: I heard you're called the O'Sullivan of Beiyou
其他人：我是北邮塞尔比
Jake:我们一辆车能抓几个人
Jake: How many people can we catch in one car?
Shure: 如果是6个人去的话就可以
Shure: If six people go, it should be fine
Shure: 有个人能留在这帮我配环境
Shure: Someone can stay here and help me set up the environment
Jake:哈哈哈要不然就是你吧
Jake: Hahaha, why don't you do it then
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jack: 那你可以在这配环境
Jack: Then you can stay here and set up the environment
Jack: 不是你先搞一个贝斯
Jack: First, get the base ready
Jack: 你贝斯如果搞好剩下就只等时间
Jack: Once the base is ready, the rest is just waiting for time
Jack: 你可以把开放式装起来就走
Jack: You can set up the open part and then leave
Jack: 回来就装好
Jack: When you come back, it will be done
Shure: 他现在自己在这装呢
Shure: He's setting it up himself now
Shure: 我可以再开一个命令行一起装吗
Shure: Can I open another command line to set it up together?
Jack: 别我建议吧
Jack: No, I suggest not
Shure: 啊好
Shure: Ah, okay
Jake:哈哈哈嗯好介意
Jake: Hahaha, alright, we mind
Shure: 那这个他5下载速度是500K每秒
Shure: His download speed is 500K per second
其他人：现在挺好吧
Others: It's good now, right?
Shure: 我估计差不多
Shure: I think it's about right
Shure: 回来它能装好都不错了是吧
Shure: If it installs fine when we come back, it’s good, right?
Jake:行啊走吧走吧走吧
Jake: Alright, let's go, let's go, let's go
Shure: 咱们全全员都去是吧
Shure: We're all going, right?
Jake:两辆车走吧
Jake: Let's take two cars
Jake:全员都去
Jake:在打一辆
Tasha:12341234
Tasha: 1234, 1234
Alice:我在家吧
Alice: I'll stay home
Alice:我在家吧在家等着那个快递
Alice: I'll stay home and wait for that package
其他人：紫藤不来了
Jake:紫藤不来了
Jake:行那
Jake: Alright then
Tasha: 12341234
Tasha: 1234, 1234
其他人：对的一个能4个
Others: Yes, one can fit 4
其他人：一个能5个
Others: One can fit 5
Jake:走打车去哪啊
Jake: Let's go, get a cab, where are we going?
Jake:我们别去
Jake: Let's not go there
Jake:我们换一家超市
Jake: Let's go to another supermarket
Shure: 那你们有山姆会员吗
Shure: Do you guys have a Sam's Club membership?
Tasha: 建议山姆的话有18公里那么远了
Tasha: If we're going to Sam's Club, it's 18 kilometers away
Jack: 稍微远一点好像有通州区万达
Lucia:那个在通州北苑那是吧好像
Lucia: That one is in Tongzhou Beiyuan, right?
Jack: 挺近的反正我好像看到
Jack: It's pretty close, I think I saw it
Shure: 只要有超市的地方要去
Shure: Anywhere there's a supermarket, we should go
Tasha: 超市儿
Jake:超市儿
Jake: Supermarket.
其他人：那就万达呗卧槽七公里
Others: Then let's go to Wanda, damn, it's seven kilometers away.
Jack: 七公里开车二十多分钟
Jack: Seven kilometers, driving will take more than twenty minutes.
Shure: 他是卡了吗
Shure: Is he stuck?
Shure: 他怎么不动弹呢
Shure: Why isn't he moving?
Jake:万达超市是什么超市
Jake: What kind of supermarket is Wanda?
Shure: 永辉吧
Jack: Yonghui.
Jack: 永辉
Jake:永辉
Jake: Yonghui.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake:那就去永辉
Jake: Then let's go to Yonghui.
Jake:去永辉好
Jake: Going to Yonghui is good.
其他人：半个小时我看看还有没有大超市
其他人：靖康靖康你买那个大横幅了吗
Jake:我没买没买
Jake: I didn't buy it, didn't buy it.
Jake:没设计出来
Jake: Didn't design it.
Shure: 他这有一个完完整的教程
Shure: He has a complete tutorial here.
Shure: 你就按着他来就行
Shure: Just follow it exactly.
Jake:回回头P一下
Jake: I'll Photoshop it later.
Shure: 这个可能要装很久
Shure: This might take a long time to install.
Shure: 然后他他现在卡在这了
Shure: Now it's stuck here.
Shure: 他如果error的话你就按下上键
Shure: If it errors, press the up key.
Shure: 然后你再按下回车
Shure: Then press Enter.
Shure: 哎算了我手机控制吧
Shure: Eh, forget it, I'll control it with my phone.
Jack: 你还可以这么牛逼
Jack: You can do that? That's impressive.
其他人：卧槽这个我真hold不住
Others: Damn, I really can't handle this.
Jack: 手机控电脑
Jack: Controlling the computer with your phone.
Jake:就万达是吧
Jake: So, we're going to Wanda, right?
Nicous: 啊这附近有个物美
Nicous: Yeah, there's a Wumart nearby.
Shure: 嗯直接把这个给带是吧
Jake:物美很小
其他人：建议万达
其他人：没有你看这外边看着还挺大的
Jake:打电话问问要不
Jake:假的吧假的
Jake:是假的吧
Shure: 啊向日葵
Jake:看给哪个商家一个表现的机会
Lucia:今天好热呀
Lucia: It's so hot today.
Tasha:是的嘞
Tasha: Yeah, it is.
Tasha: 明天更热
Tasha: It'll be even hotter tomorrow.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Uh-huh.
Tasha: 我说明天更热了
Tasha: I mean, it'll be even hotter tomorrow.
Lucia: 怎么了
Tasha: 我好像没有吃啥
Tasha: I don't think I've eaten anything.
Tasha: 感觉喉咙里面有刀片一样
Tasha: Feels like there's a blade in my throat.
Tasha:没事
Tasha: It's okay.
Lucia: 是吃什么东西太辣了吗还是怎么回事
Tasha:吸到烟味了
Tasha: Inhaled some smoke.
Lucia:哦这样
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Jake:刘帅哪去了
Jake: Where did Choiszt go?
Katrina: 你要看一下有没有蓝色吗
Katrina: Do you want to check if there's any blue?
Katrina: 好像有唉
Katrina: Looks like there is.
Lucia:嗯哎我觉得可以
Lucia: Hmm, I think this will work.
Lucia:那我就蹭你这个好了
Lucia: I'll just use yours then.
Katrina: 你拿吧反正也做不完
Katrina: Go ahead, I won't finish it anyway.
Katrina: 没几朵花
Katrina: There aren't many flowers left.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Katrina: 反正是杨老
Katrina: Anyway, it's on Jake.
Katrina: 板报销的
Katrina: He's paying for it.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Tasha: 有啊
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 在在车上玩了
Tasha: I was playing in the car.
Tasha: 你你你不是又要说我啊
Tasha: You, you, you're not going to scold me again, right?
Tasha:这次真的不会输给我
Tasha: This time you really won't beat me.
Lucia:我们今天的快递是还没送过来吗
Lucia: Has our package not arrived yet today?
Tasha: 你你能打过我吗
Tasha: Do you think you can beat me?
Lucia: 还是送过来了一些
Lucia: okay i see i guess this is mine
Lucia: 这果然是我的
Lucia: 哎呀不愧是我
Lucia: 一眼就认出了自己的快递
Lucia: 好弱智啊
其他人：啊这么快
其他人：你说500K我不信
Shure: 那我估计就是他上午的时候
Jake:缓存就是缓存
Jake:装了多少遍了不存点东西
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Lucia: 今天好热啊
Alice:晒的慌
Lucia: 是的
Lucia: 嗯我们还有红柚汁
Jake:有但是不多
Lucia: Mojito的基酒是不是也是龙舌兰来着
Lucia: 我靠等一下
Lucia: 我这两天是不是不能喝酒我靠
Lucia: 可恶不然可以
Jake:那就多买果汁吧
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: 大家喝我可以帮大家调
Lucia: 但我不是
Lucia: 我是有点担心我调出来那个
Lucia: 因为
Lucia: 我不知道大家分别喜欢多重的酒味
Lucia: 我还蛮喜欢龙舌兰的
Shure: 我当你的舌头
Lucia: 哈哈哈我喝一点点应该没事吧
Shure: 最好还是别打疫苗还是别
Lucia:啊你给小狗做了花花好好看
Lucia: Ah, you made flowers for the puppy, they look great!
Jake:哦插脑袋上了
Jake: Oh, you put them on its head.
Katrina: 还有充电宝吗
Katrina: Do we have any more power banks?
Tasha: 平板平板你在哪里呢
Tasha: Tablet, tablet, where are you?
Lucia: 这个是不是可以扔了
其他人：我递烟你递宝
Jake:要宝吗
Lucia: 这个自带线的充电宝真的很不错
Lucia: 少带一根线
Lucia:  这样可以
其他人：不行你有线吗
其他人：就哪个带线那个
其他人：那个比较畅销啊
Jack: 刘帅改变了主意
Jack: Choiszt changed his mind.
其他人：他决定先去看
其他人：因为他觉得档次不如永辉
Jake:他他先去看看是什么意思
其他人：先去看看档次够不够
Jake:所以我们先去哪儿
Jake: So, where are we going first?
Shure: 刘帅才干嘛去了
Shure: Where did Choiszt go?
Jake:他在外面坐着呢
Jake: He's sitting outside.
Shure: 啊哈
Shure: Aha.
Shure: 那我们现在干嘛
Shure: So, what are we doing now?
Jake:打电话问问呗
Jake: Let's call and ask.
Jake:问问物美你档次够不够啊
Jake: Ask if Wumart is good enough.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 没办法京爷就是这个样子的
Shure: There's no choice, that's just how Jingye is.
Lucia:你什么档次也敢出镜哈哈哈
Lucia: You dare to appear on camera with that level, haha.
Shure: 脑袋炸的时候
Lucia: 筷子
Shure: 你用公费买了jellycat
Lucia: 哎我也买了一只
Lucia: 因为它颜色刚好跟我计划的颜色一样
Katrina: 那可不那送给自己的不会为了这个
Katrina: 送我还差不多
Shure: 那你要追人家就应该主动一点
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: 看你是跑的快还是拉的快
Lucia: 哎呦妈呀
Lucia: shit
Shure: 爱情是你独特味道
Shure: 在我地球闪耀
Shure: 别人都不了
Shure: 只有你知道
Shure: 因为你世界不再单调
Shure: 你的微笑
Jake:你明天跳吧
Lucia: 你明天跳吧
Jake:给你搭舞台
Jake:我们是永辉
Jake:有没有舞台
Lucia: 我觉得你这个特别好
Lucia: 怎么能形容
Lucia: 半小时速成的
Lucia: 已经速成的
Lucia: 非常好啊啊
Jake:就是是学出来的吗
Lucia: 刚那个动作
Lucia: 不是那天那个
Shure: 不是不是
Lucia: 哈哈哦
Lucia: 所以你是solo的freestyle
Shure: 根据歌词solo的
Jake:牛啊
Shure: 爱情是你独特的味道
Shure: 在我地球闪耀
Shure: 别人都不了
Shure: 只有你知道
Shure: 还没给钱
Shure: 怎么样是不是很懂
Lucia: 这个问题有价值啊
Lucia: 终于不再是弱智霸问题了
Shure: AI永远理解不了这些问题
Lucia: 等什么哈哈哈
其他人：你可以去采树苗喂我草
其他人：为什么会
Shure: 好的好的
Alice:好吗好的
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: 别哈哈
Lucia: 你这话说完
Lucia: 我觉得咱屋里一下多了好多人
Lucia: 哈哈哈好吗
Shure: 好吗好的哈哈
Shure: 不要再拿我们家大哥的梗了好吗
Lucia: 好的哈哈
Lucia: 你坏
Alice:大兵打人算群殴吗
Lucia: 哈哈哈打人算群殴
Lucia: 这算的吧
Lucia: 怎么不算一种群殴呢
Shure: 它可以biu的一下甩出去你看
Lucia: 哇
Shure: 太酷了吧
Lucia: 我我初中的时候经常这样
Lucia:  开伞就啪甩出去哈哈
Shure: 没有一个男生能拒绝一个非常直的棍子
Lucia: 哈哈
Shure: do you know bravo
Shure: Do you know bravo?
Lucia: 正月烫头
Shure: 正月里来是新年啊
Shure: 大年初一头一天啊
Shure: The first day of the new year.
Shure: 家家团圆味啊
Shure: Families reunite.
Shure: 咱们什么时候出发呀
Shure: When are we leaving?
Lucia: 这包的开关在哪
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Alice:问什么时候来
Alice: Ask when it's coming.
Alice:送快递
Alice: The delivery.
Jake:我这车还有9分8分钟到
Jake: My car will be here in about 9 to 8 minutes.
Lucia: 棒棒
Jake:这狗是每个人放门口
Jake: This dog is at everyone's door.
Jake:我们也得做点
Jake: We should do something too.
Jack: 哦这是要干嘛
Jack: Oh, what are we doing?
Alice:我的狗还没啊
Alice: My dog isn't here yet.
Lucia: 还要给它夹花花吗
Lucia: Do we still need to put flowers on it?
Alice:不是我那个腿还没剪呢
Alice: No, I haven't trimmed the legs yet.
Lucia: 啊你后面这样
Lucia: Ah, the back like this.
Lucia: 没事没事这样已经很好看了
Lucia: It's okay, it looks good already.
Alice:面条子
Alice: Noodles.
Jake:火车地铁狗
Lucia: 我是内有恶犬
Alice:剪刀在哪啊
Alice: Where are the scissors?
Lucia: 套装勿拆
Lucia: Don't open the set.
Lucia: 因为内有恶犬
Lucia: Because there's a vicious dog inside.
Lucia: 哎可以可以
Lucia: Hey, it works.
Lucia: 给他写给他写套装勿拆内有恶犬
Lucia: Write on it, "Don't open the set, there's a vicious dog inside."
Jake:剪刀这边有
Jake: There are scissors here.
Alice:这个不太利
Alice:另一个在哪
Alice: Where's the other one?
Lucia: 另一个其实也不太利
Lucia: The other one isn't very sharp either.
Lucia: 比这能好点不
Lucia: Is it better than this?
Jake:菜刀强一点
Jake: A kitchen knife is stronger.
Jake:这有俩菜刀
Jake: There are two kitchen knives here.
Lucia: 菜刀不能控制方向呀
Jake: You can't control the direction with a kitchen knife.
Lucia: 你只能直着剪
Jake: You can only cut straight.
Lucia: 给菜刀烫头
Lucia: Give the kitchen knife a perm.
Jake:那
Jake: Well...
Jake:上面有吗
Jake: Is it on top?
Katrina: 问你个问题
Katrina: Let me ask you a question.
Katrina: 北京西站离什刹海远吗
Katrina: Is Beijing West Station far from Shichahai?
Lucia: 北京西什刹海好像在很中间的地方
Lucia: Beijing West and Shichahai seem to be quite central.
Alice:什刹海在中间
Alice: Shichahai is in the center.
Katrina: 什刹海在
Katrina: Shichahai is...
Katrina: 东直门是不是
Katrina: Near Dongzhimen, right?
Jake:什刹海算很中间吧正轴线
Jake:正轴线了没有东西
Lucia: 就是这个这个这个大水
Lucia: It's this big water area...
Lucia: 这个附近应该就是什刹海
Lucia: Nearby should be Shichahai.
Lucia: 我要没记错的话
Lucia: If I remember correctly.
Lucia: 我也有一段时间没来了
Lucia: It's been a while since I last came here.
Jake:走个两环
Jake: Walk two rings.
Jake:跨两环
Jake: Cross two rings.
Jake:很近啊北京哪都近
其他人：哦哦
Others: Oh, oh...
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
Jake:相对于通州而言
Jake: Compared to Tongzhou...
Jake:我们人在北京
Jake: We're in Beijing.
Jake:相对于通州而言
Jake: Compared to Tongzhou...
Lucia: 我觉得北京哪都远
Jack: 我想我在上海这个地方确实是近
Jack: I think here in Shanghai, it's really close.
Jack: 就可以走走路
Jack: You can just walk.
Lucia: 我觉得我本科都不怎么出学校
Lucia: I feel like I didn't leave campus much during undergrad.
Lucia: 出去学校太累了
Lucia: Leaving campus was too tiring.
Jack: 我出学校都打车所以还好
Jack: 所以啊
Jack: So, yeah...
Lucia: 你是在紫金宿舍还是在南区
Lucia: Are you at Zijin Dorm or the South Area?
Jack: 南区现在已经是高贵的强基计划
Jack: The South Area is now for the prestigious Qiangji program.
Lucia: 这样的吗
Jack: 新雅和强基
Jack: Xinya and Qiangji.
Lucia: 那经管男生
Lucia: 现在是在我
Lucia: Now they're at...
Lucia: 因为我
Lucia: Because I...
Lucia: 我们那会好像他们最早在31号楼
Lucia: Back then, they were in Building 31.
Lucia: 但后来好像搬到了南区
Lucia: But later, they moved to the South Area.
Jack: 现在应该还在紫金吧
Jack: They should still be at Zijin now.
Lucia: 紫金去上课真是把人累死
Lucia: Going to class from Zijin is exhausting.
Jack: 确实所以我从大二开始就不上课
Jack: Right, that's why I stopped going to class from sophomore year.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈excuse me
Lucia: Hahaha, excuse me.
Jake:解决了问题
Jake: Problem solved.
Lucia: 从根本上解决问题
Jack: 非常非常好解决
Jack: It's really, really easy to solve.
Jack: 就睡睡到自然醒
Jack: Just sleep until you wake up naturally.
Jack: 然后然后去图书馆
Jack: Then go to the library.
Jack: 是记得去图书馆
Jack: Remember to go to the library.
Jack: 这个南区跟紫金基本一样
Jack: The south district and Zijin are basically the same.
Lucia: 去图书馆我应该不用爬那个好汉坡
Jake:走吧来
Jake: Let's go, come on.
Lucia: 要命了
Lucia: It's killing me.
Shure: 现在想想我都心有余悸
Shure: Just thinking about it still scares me.
Alice:我的狗放在门口吧
Alice: I'll leave my dog at the door.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: 会不会刮风
Lucia: 我都行我都行
Lucia: 可以给他们肚子里塞一些石头
其他人：物美见是吗
Jake:物美见
Lucia: 没有我随口一说
Alice:这样呗就
Lucia: 可以可以
其他人：哪些人跟刘帅呀
Lucia: 好可爱啊
Lucia: 我要给他俩拍个照
其他人：我靠确实可爱
其他人：一个叫小猫一个叫小兔
Lucia: 一个叫小猫
其他人：修硕不去去吗
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: 包都背上了
Katrina: Got my bag packed.
Shure: 我去啊怎么了
Shure: Oh, what's up?
Choiszt: 那多一个人
Choiszt: One more person.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Choiszt: 因为有一个人跟靖康咱现在不6个人吗
Choiszt: Because there's one person, the health limit is 6 people.
Katrina: 哪6个她不去
Katrina: Which 6? He's not going.
Alice:我不去
Shure: 正好
Shure: Perfect.
Katrina: 12345 OK
Katrina: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, OK.
Shure: 纸狮子
Shure: Paper lion.
Lucia: 纸狗子
Lucia: 四十四个石狮子吃四十四个石柿子
Shure: 死柿子
Shure: Dead persimmon.
Lucia: 死柿子
Lucia: Dead persimmon.
Shure: 屎柿子是什么东西
Shure: What's a poop persimmon?
Lucia: 石柿子
Lucia: Rock persimmon.
Shure: 啊石柿子
Shure: Ah, rock persimmon.
Jack: 哎你打车
Jack: Hey, you called a cab?
Jack: 在哪车
Jack: Where's the cab?
Jake:呃打车在这
Jake: Uh, the cab is here.
Jake:开车在那
Jake: Driving is over there.
Shure: 那我跟那边好
Shure: Then I'll go over there.
Tasha: 自动分流
Jake:哎把眼镜关了吧都
Lucia: 到地再开
Jake:对到地再开
Lucia: 怎么关来着我怎么突然不记得了
Jake:全去的全是盒马
Jake: All of them went to Hema.
Jake:然后我觉得
Jake: And I think...
Jake:我觉得不能给这个就是
Jake: I think we can't just...
Jake:这太BIOS了这个
Jake: This is too biased.
Jack: 小波尔全雅主义
Jack: Small world idealism.
Jake:行可以
Jake: Alright, fine.
Tasha: 谢冰竹骗我说跟我在撸皮猪上打游戏呢
Tasha: Xie Bingzhu lied to me saying he was playing games with me on LoL.
Jake:哦他没跟你打游戏
Jake: Oh, he didn't play games with you?
Jack: 里面还不是立刻超市
Jack: Isn't it still a supermarket inside?
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Jack: 是商城
Jack: It's a mall.
Lucia: 但是有榴莲耶
Lucia: But there are durians.
Tasha: 尊嘟诶
Tasha: Really?
Jake:这是什么价
Jake: What is this price?
Jake:啊这已经到超市了哈
Jake: Ah, we are already in the supermarket, huh?
Jack: 我建议先买一瓶补水
Jack: I suggest buying a bottle of water first.
Tasha: 你就不要一个购物车吗
Tasha: Don't you need a shopping cart?
Tasha: 哪有购物车
Tasha: Where's the shopping cart?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Jack: 入口吧
Jack: At the entrance, probably.
Lucia: 华为
Lucia: Huawei.
Lucia: 我去购物车在外面
Lucia: Oh, the shopping carts are outside.
Tasha: 感觉这个超市有点不太正经
Tasha: This supermarket feels a bit sketchy.
Jake:这太村了这个
Jake: This is too rural.
Lucia: 还行
Lucia: It's alright.
Lucia: 至少这次咱能把购物车推出来了
Lucia: At least we can take the shopping cart out this time.
Lucia: 乐观吧
Lucia: Be optimistic.
Jack: 至少他万向的时候
Jack: At least when it was universal...
Jack: 看起来是万向的
Jack: It looked universal.
Jake:他一直在转
Jake: It kept turning.
Jake:确实很万
Jake: Really universal.
Jack: 哇他有一点
Jack: Wow, it's a bit...
Jack: 他有点歪
Jack: It's a bit tilted.
Lucia: 他有点BIOS
Lucia: It's a bit biased.
Jack: 他为什么不转但是他右前轮转他有点BIOS
Jack: Why doesn't it turn but the right front wheel does, it's a bit biased.
Lucia: 哈哈哈还是BIOS吧
Lucia: Hahaha still biased.
Jack: 我听着有点过分
Jack: I think it's a bit too much.
Lucia: 是
Lucia: Yeah.
Jack: 他可以有BIOS
Jack: It can have bias.
Lucia: 这不是1.8A的是吧
Lucia: This isn't the 1.8A, right?
Lucia: 缺乏鲁暴性
Lucia: Lacking robustness
Lucia: 牛栏山二锅头
Lucia: Niulanshan Erguotou
Jake:二锅头
Jake: Erguotou
Lucia: 这才是真正的北京特产吧
Lucia: This is the real Beijing specialty, right?
Jack: 北京特产还行
Jack: Beijing specialty, not bad
Lucia: 本来就是嘛
Lucia: That's what it is
Tasha: 要不要把这个放在车里哦
Tasha: Should we put this in the car?
Jake:买了一个Pad
Jake: Bought a Pad
Tasha: 买了一个包
Tasha: Bought a bag
Lucia: 买了一个充电宝
Lucia: Bought a power bank
Jake:买了个人
Jake: Bought a person
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:去
Jake: Go
Tasha: 一般在超市里面吃吃喝喝
Tasha: Usually eating and drinking in the supermarket
Tasha: 然后拿着一大堆开过的去结账
Tasha: Then take a bunch of opened items to the checkout
Tasha: 也是可以的
Tasha: It's also possible
Jake:可以那咱也喝点的
Jake: Sure, we can have a drink too
Lucia: 你要报菜名了吗
Lucia: Are you going to name the dishes?
Tasha: 哈哈我我我已经开始报
Tasha: Haha, I already started
Lucia: 哈哈冰糖雪梨冰红茶
Lucia: Haha, rock sugar pear, iced red tea
Lucia: 可口可乐
Lucia: Coca-Cola
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Lucia: 没有常温的嘛
Lucia: Don't they have room temperature?
Jack: 常温好像在那边
Jack: Room temperature seems to be over there
Lucia: 那我一会到那边再喝吧
Lucia: Then I'll drink it over there later
Lucia: 薇薇看看想喝什么
Lucia: Tasha, see what you want to drink
Tasha: 我想喝库尔橙汁
Tasha: I want Cool orange juice
Lucia: 哦那个我也好久没喝了
Lucia: Oh, I haven't had that in a long time
Lucia: 有一个叫库尔
Lucia: There's one called Cool
Jake:哦库尔
Jake: Oh, Cool
Jack: 哦是那个
Jack: Oh, it's that one
Lucia: 对小时候好像很常见呀
Lucia: Yeah, it was quite common when we were kids
Jack: 动画表情那个小孩
Jack: The cartoon character kid
Jack: 哦还真的是有二十年
Jack: Oh, it really has been twenty years
Shure: 呦呦
Shure: Yo yo
Lucia: 上面这二层看着像仓储式超市一样
Lucia: The upper floor looks like a warehouse-style supermarket
Jack: 你这车有BIOS
Jack: Does your car have BIOS?
Lucia: 仓储式就是Costco那种
Lucia: Warehouse-style, like Costco
Shure: 应该也有唉
Shure: It should have it too.
Jack: 他这车BIOS不是很强
Jack: His car's BIOS isn't very strong.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey
Shure: 啾啾啾突突突突突
Shure: Pew pew pew pew pew
Lucia: 谢冰竹是不是找不到我们了
Lucia: Is Xie Bingzhu lost and can't find us?
Jake:我们一起打他电话
Jake: Let's all call him
Tasha: 呼叫失败
Tasha: Call failed
Lucia: 会忙线吧
Lucia: The line might be busy.
Lucia: 一起打
Lucia: Let's call together.
Jake:我们一起打他电话
Jake: Let's call him together.
Jake:看谁能打到
Jake: See who gets through.
Lucia: 这算群殴吗
Lucia: Is this considered a group attack?
Shure: do do do
Shure: Do do do
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:我四个谢冰竹
Jake: I have four Xie Bingzhu.
Lucia: 这算群殴吗
Lucia: Is this considered a group attack?
Tasha: 呼叫失败
Tasha: Call failed.
Lucia: 我微信网络不稳定i don'tknowwhy
Lucia: My WeChat network is unstable, I don't know why.
Katrina: 可乐拿一个
Katrina: Grab a cola.
Lucia: 我现在用的应该是移动
Lucia: I think I'm using Mobile right now.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Lucia: 不是电信的网啊
Lucia: Not Telecom's network.
Lucia: 怎么还这么差
Lucia: Why is it still so bad?
Tasha: 对方忙
Tasha: The other party is busy.
Jake:那接一个
Jake: Then answer one.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Lucia: 你这个t恤标志换了
Lucia: You changed the logo on your T-shirt.
Jake:哎是
Jake: Oh, yes.
Jake:对这是第一版
Jake: Yes, this is the first version.
Lucia: 变成他们学校的校徽了
Lucia: It became their school badge.
Shure: 不够
Shure: Not enough.
Jake:这不是
Jake: No, it's not.
Jack: 商汤
Jack: Shangtang.
Katrina: 真的吗不是只有调调酒吗
Katrina: Really? Isn't it just for mixing drinks?
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What to do?
Tasha: 他不接你打电话吧
Tasha: He won't answer your call, right?
Shure: 大家喝呢
Shure: Everyone's drinking.
Jake:我欠费
Jake: I'm out of credit.
Shure: 就是只给来了gas的喝水是吗
Shure: So we only give water to those who came for gas?
Tasha: 欠费了哈哈哈
Tasha: Out of credit, hahaha.
Jake:停机了
Jake: My phone is disconnected.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Katrina: 喝RIO吧
Katrina: Let's drink RIO.
Lucia: 他刚解释过
Lucia: He just explained.
Katrina: 想喝那个桃子味的
Katrina: I want the peach flavor.
Lucia: 这个刚解释过
Lucia: He just explained this.
Jake:打不出去电话
Jake: I can't make a call.
Shure: RIO
Jake:那就换一个人打吧
Jake: Then let's have someone else call.
Jake:打刘帅
Jake: Call Choiszt.
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Jack: 他不应该在门口啊
Jack: Shouldn't he be at the door?
Jake:可能找不到
Jake: Maybe he can't be found.
Katrina: 要不要直接拿一提啊
Katrina: Should we just grab a case?
Tasha: 感觉这个超市好小啊
Tasha: This supermarket feels so small.
Jake:这个超市
Jake: This supermarket...
Shure: 行
Shure: Sure.
Jake:对一开就开过了
Jake: Yeah, it opened a long time ago.
Tasha: 就是那种开了二三十年的感觉
Tasha: It feels like it's been open for twenty or thirty years.
Shure: 刚才拿一提就好了
Shure: We should've grabbed a case earlier.
Lucia: 没事给AI增加一些数据多样性
Lucia: It's okay, it adds data diversity for AI.
Katrina: 3个这3个味的都好喝
Katrina: All three of these flavors are good.
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, it does.
Shure: 这三个是一样的吧
Shure: Aren't these three the same?
Jake:不能总盒马太赛博了
Jake: We can't always rely on Hema, it's too cyber.
Katrina: 不是
Katrina: No.
Shure: 哦不是啊
Shure: Oh, they're not?
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 二锅头你们东北那喝二锅头是吗
Katrina: Erguotou, do you guys drink Erguotou in the Northeast?
Tasha: 没加他算了
Tasha: Forget it, we didn't add him.
Shure: 北京喝二锅头
Shure: In Beijing, we drink Erguotou.
Katrina: 雪花啤酒
Katrina: Snow Beer.
Shure: 这是那种复古包装的雪花啤酒
Shure: This is the retro-packaged Snow Beer.
Shure: 我们家那边的雪花
Shure: It's from my hometown's Snow Beer.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Jake:路亚也来打鱼啊
Jake: Is Lure also coming to fish?
Katrina: 苏打水要拿吗上次的
Katrina: Should we grab some soda water, like last time?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yes.
Tasha: 什么怎么说我们都开始逛了
Tasha: What, how come we started wandering around?
Shure: 上次拿那还没喝呢
Shure: We still haven't finished the ones from last time.
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Tasha: 就是这个
Tasha: It's this one.
Shure: 没有没喝呢
Shure: No, we haven't drunk them yet.
Tasha: 终于打通了
Tasha: Finally got through.
Jake:哦这个你打通了
Jake: Oh, you got through this one.
Katrina: 哎元气森林
Katrina: Oh, Yuanqi Forest.
Jake:哎你好
Jake: Hey, hello.
Katrina: 这下有元气森林了吧
Katrina: They have Yuanqi Forest now.
Jake:哈哈你好啊
Jake: Haha, hello there.
Shure: 葡萄味的是吧
Shure: The grape flavor, right?
Jake:你在哪里啊
Jake: Where are you?
Katrina: 对对对感觉那葡萄汁兑的一般般
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, but the grape juice mix is just so-so.
Lucia: 怎么跟第一次见面一样
Lucia: It's like meeting for the first time.
Tasha: 哪位啊
Tasha: Who is it?
Lucia: 对哈哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, haha.
Shure: 随便
Shure: Whatever.
Jake:地下停车场
Jake: Underground parking.
Jake:行行行我们在
Jake: Alright, alright, we're here.
Jake:我们到华为等你们
Jake: We'll wait for you at Huawei.
Shure: 最后喝不了你就带走当奖金了是吧
Shure: In the end, if we can't drink it, we'll just take it home as a bonus, right?
Jake:在华为我们去华为等你们
Jake: At Huawei, we'll wait for you at Huawei.
Shure: 拿点易带走
Shure: Take something easy to carry.
Jake:华为华为
Jake: Huawei, Huawei.
Shure: 然后并且很贵的那种
Shure: And something expensive.
Jake:对一楼一楼华为
Jake: Yes, first floor, Huawei.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 比如说拿两瓶基酒
Shure: Like grab two bottles of base liquor.
Lucia: 一楼华为
Lucia: First floor, Huawei.
Shure: 然后到时候哎
Shure: And then, hey,
Shure: 打包回去吧
Shure: pack it up and take it home.
Katrina: 带回我们宿舍
Katrina: Take it back to our dorm.
Katrina: 我们宿舍有福了
Katrina: Our dorm is gonna be blessed.
Katrina: 有点像那种打猎回来
Katrina: It's kinda like coming back from hunting.
Lucia: 那不是正儿八经的华为吧
Lucia: That's not the real Huawei, right?
Lucia: 那卖的可是衣服啊大哥
Lucia: They sell clothes there, dude.
Shure: 孩子们
Shure: Kids,
Katrina: 我回来了
Katrina: I'm back.
Katrina: 订的24号下午2点的票
Katrina: Booked tickets for the 24th at 2 PM.
Jake:我说那是华为
Jake: I said it's Huawei.
Jake:那是不是华为
Jake: Isn't it Huawei?
Lucia: 是是是是
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 您说不是
Lucia: If you say it's not,
Lucia: 不是您说是
Lucia: then it's not. If you say it is,
Lucia: 谁敢说不是
Lucia: who dares to say otherwise?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 风轻轻吹进了你的心
Shure: The wind gently blows into your heart.
Lucia: 那必须是
Lucia: It has to be.
Katrina: 哎杯子打碎了还够吗
Katrina: Hey, if the cup breaks, do we still have enough?
Lucia: 你倒着推他会
Lucia: If you push him backwards,
Katrina: 可不可以直接让管家拿
Katrina: Can we just ask the butler to bring some?
Lucia: 他会更稳一点吗
Lucia: will it be more stable?
Katrina: 就不自己买了
Katrina: So we don't have to buy them ourselves.
Katrina: 反也带不走
Katrina: Can't take them anyway.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Jake:因为他前面导向的是稳定的
Jake: Because it's more stable when he guides from the front.
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: No idea.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Got it.
Shure: 要不都咱们这次要用一次性的东西吗
Shure: How about we use disposable stuff this time?
Jake:那你坐
Jake: Then you sit down.
Shure: 啊我不想刷了
Shure: Ah, I don't want to wash them.
Lucia: 坐这个吧浅一点好坐哈哈哈
Lucia: Sit on this one, it's shallower and more comfortable, haha.
Shure: 虽然不符合我们这个Eagle life的理念吧
Shure: Even though it doesn't fit with our Eagle life philosophy.
Nicous: 但我们不能
Nicous: But we can't...
Shure: 我们我们能用一次性餐具之类的吗
Shure: Can we use disposable tableware and such?
Jake:不环保不环保
Jake: Not eco-friendly, not eco-friendly.
Lucia: 高温烧制
Lucia: High-temperature firing.
Shure: 是不符合
Shure: It doesn't fit.
Katrina: 那上次那个杯子打碎几个
Katrina: How many cups broke last time?
Tasha: 猜他是釉上彩还是釉下彩
Tasha: Guess if it's overglaze or underglaze?
Katrina: 那明天人更多了
Katrina: There'll be more people tomorrow.